last month Tesla made one of the biggest
price drops in EV history slashing its
model y by nearly 20 percent the move
sent shockwaves through the Auto
industry a few weeks later Ford made its
own price cut on the electric Mustang
Mach e analysts and experts have been
watching to see if other car makers will
follow
while these price cuts are good news for
consumers they could also be a sign that
the tide is changing in the EB industry
so what can Tesla and Ford's price
changes tell us about the future of the
EV Market
sticker price cuts across a company's
lineup or on a specific vehicle are
quite rare in the Auto industry though
not unheard of most automakers use
incentive campaigns that can change from
month to month to lower prices Tesla and
Ford's price Cuts surprised many in the
industry because EV prices have been
steadily increasing for the last year or
so the cost of making the battery and
some other parts of the EV are just
steadily increasing as well so to absorb
those Rising costs companies have had to
increase their prices on some Vehicles
supply chain constraints pinched
inventory and drove prices higher in
addition to Rising commodity costs the
amount that Tesla slashed off its prices
also came as a surprise analysts agreed
that it was really a move to grab market
share Tesla is already the number one
seller of EVS in the U.S but you know
they have Ambitions to sell even more
Vehicles than they do right now Tesla
said it wanted to lower prices enough to
qualify many models for a 7 500 federal
tax credit to lure in new buyers though
on February 3rd the treasury Department
said it will relax its rules classifying
cars like the Tesla Model Y and Ford
Machi as SUVs which should qualify most
of those models for that federal tax
credit even at their original higher
prices it remains to be seen what impact
the change will have on EV pricing but
Elon Musk has been clear lowering prices
is a priority for Tesla price really
matters
um I think because
just a vast number of people that want
to buy a Tesla car
can't afford it and and so these price
changes really make a difference they
hit percent off of a vehicle it doesn't
automatically mean they're losing a lot
of money on these vehicles but Ford is
in a different situation though it's the
number two EV seller in the US it still
lags way behind Tesla in market share
the competitor like Ford that has
Slimmer margins to work with they might
be losing money on their vehicles when
they cut prices Ford made their first
all-electric SUV a Mustang a Ford
executive last year said that it's Maki
was losing money because of the rising
costs around the battery which is the
most expensive part of the EV you're
going to see pressure on the bottom line
when we launch rebs right they're not
going to be positive we've said that
Ford said it's been able to reduce
prices on the Maki because its supply
chain is more efficient now and
production costs are coming down they
definitely are chasing Tesla and you
know they have a large gap to make up to
get to that and clearly with their
response just in the last week or so
they think it's important to be
competitive with Tesla on the pricing
front as the market leader Tesla can
make pricing decisions that put pressure
on competitors but so far Ford is one of
the only companies that responded with
its own price cut for companies like GM
and Volkswagen and you know we may be
hearing from others they've been saying
we see the price Cuts but we're staying
our ground and we don't think it's
necessary to adjust our pricing at all
we have high demand with where we're
currently priced and that's that some
analysts have called Tesla's price Cuts
an attempt at starting an EV pricing War
but the lack of action so far from most
car makers suggests that it might be too
soon to tell we'll have to see how
pricing moves in the next few months but
for now I'd say you know it's
competitive there's definitely some
tension companies are making strategic
shifts but it doesn't seem for now like
a full-on price war is breaking out but
there is tremendous pressure on EV
sellers right now to poach as many
customers as they can from Tesla and
keeping prices competitive is an
effective tactic what's keeping
customers from buying an EV price price
is a big thing so it's just another tool
that some companies are using to try to
lure in new buyers in this increasingly
Cutthroat environment so what does all
of this mean for the EV Market the
takeaway for customers right now is
hopefully you know you've got a few more
affordable UV options to buy from and
maybe this means that there will be some
change in pricing on other models in the
future for other Brands prices could
also increase throughout the year
especially if battery costs keep Rising
already we've seen some slight increases
on on some Tesla models because Elon
Musk has said that demand is so great
that they've been able to bump up those
prices you know really slightly so an EV
pricing War hasn't broken out just yet
but analysts and experts say they will
be watching earnings calls in the coming
months to see how the price Cuts affect
Tesla and Ford's bottom line